this is a production of Cornell
University Thank You Magdalene as she
said my name is Daniel Sweeney I'm a
fourth year PhD candidate in mark
Searles lab and the section of plant
protein genetics now we talked a little
bit today about accelerating malting
barley brooding order making beer in New
York so there are over 400 craft
breweries in New York and many of these
can be directly attributed to the
passage of the New York State farm
brewery bill in 2012 this provided
economic incentives for local breweries
to use locally produced hops and malt
this law mandates that malting barley be
produced in New York to go into the New
York beer this is all well and good but
producing high-quality malting barley in
New York is difficult due to the wet and
humid summers that we tend to have which
can have detrimental effects on quality
and yield so our goal is to quickly
breed superior malting barley variety
for New York that makes great beer and
can stand up to our crazy summer weather
so our strategy is to use genomic
prediction and many of you are likely
familiar with this for those that aren't
genomic prediction enables unfilled
typed lines to have their genetic value
predicted solely based on genome-wide
molecular markers and this is useful
because it potentially reduces or even
eliminates the need for time intensive
fields phenotyping our strategy to
increase and maximize our prediction
accuracy of superior progeny was to use
a highly structured population composes
seven families across to a single common
parent this enabled us to have high
prediction accuracy for agronomic traits
disease traits and quality traits this
population structure also enabled us to
have high power for genome-wide
Association studies on the top right and
we're not interested in the genetic
architecture per se of these traits but
in using these marker trade associations
to plug back into our genomic prediction
models and the the chart on the bottom
right shows that when we add some of
these markers
trade associations back if the job
prediction model we can have increased
prediction accuracy at small training
population sizes and for high
heritability traits which is potentially
useful for us now on the applied side of
things we've taken the better lines from
this channel' prediction training
population use them to initiate a
recurrent genomic selection project
that's ongoing but also enter them into
regional yield trials last year and this
year we don't have a good understanding
of the genotype by environment
interaction formats and quality of New
York which is important because to make
consistently good craft beer you have to
have consistently good grain and craft
beer it needs to be good so that's it's
all about the flavor of the taste so
we're hoping that this data set of two
years and five locations each will
enable us to pick apart the GBI
interactions a little bit we're also
hopeful that we'll be able to select a
variety out of these trials after the
growing season this summer with
foundation C in 2020 and potential
release to farmers in 2021 lastly we're
also looking a lot into genotyping and
phenotyping methods to improve our
understanding of pre-harvest sprouting
and barley
this is a phenomenon that occurs when
grain prematurely loses dormancy in the
fields before harvest and when it's
exposed to excessive humidity or rain it
will begin to germinate in the field
this obviously has the tremenda quality
so we're looking at - phenotyping
methods greenhouse based mist assays as
well as a piece of equipment called a
rapid visco analyzer to better
understand what's going on with this
phenotype and also using - recently
developed markers tagging - cloned
prehistoric related genes in barley
with that I'd like to thank the various
members in Soros lab as well as some
other sip slabs of our funding sources
and I'd be happy to take any questions
so the question was what do we do if we
do have large gie effects over years and
locations for the malting traits ideally
we're gonna be selecting something
that's stable we want to lower the risk
for farmers as much as possible because
the difference between animal feed grade
barley and malt and quality Barty barley
can be eight to ten dollars a bushel so
ideally we want stability but
potentially we can we've might be able
to identify two or three lines that are
better adapted to maybe one to western
New York once the Finger Lakes Watson
Valley hopefully we can find stability
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu